[Music]
hi my name is Sava suppress a TV some
Cortana's architects and co-founder M we
are here to present cortana who is your
personal assistant AC is being used by
about 150 million users so today across
the PC Android iOS Xbox and very soon by
a device like this on the what we call
the intelligent speaker at home Cortana
follows you wherever you are and C tries
to understand you so she can provide you
with the best personalized experience
you can get from a personal assistant
Cortana read your email so she can
understand the commitments that you're
making to others and remind you when
there a commitment our commitment is you
see tracks your appointments so she
knows where you need to be at what time
and scene for scene for review if there
is traffic along the way to ensure that
you are on your where you need to be at
the right time she allows you to attract
a your grocery list
she will let you play music she will
allow you to stream a news related
podcast and in general Cortana is your
personal assistant helping you to be
productive and in gone with your life
helping you save a time you should try
and use it on your PC and run fine on
the iPhone or your Android device thank
you